we have obviously numerous people we
have a list of 25 people that I actually
had during my election we have a very
excellent list of great talented highly
educated highly intelligent hopefully
tremendous people it will be somebody
from that list if the president
nominates someone extraordinary like
Neil Gorsuch again I think it's very
hard to stop that kind of a nomination
the American people were widely
supportive of Neil Gorsuch and justice
course which had bipartisan support in
the Senate a big day with the
announcement that Justice Anthony
Kennedy a swing vote in so many
different cases the US Supreme Court is
retiring next month he sent a letter to
President Trump and then met with the
president saying this letter is a
respectful and formal notification of my
decision
effective July 31st of this year to end
my regular active status as an Associate
Justice of the Supreme Court for a
member of the legal profession it is the
highest of honors to serve on this Court
please permit me by this letter to
express my profound gratitude for having
had the privilege to seek in each case
how to best know interpret and defend
the Constitution and the laws that must
always conform to its mandates and
promises with that let's bring in our
panel charles herd opinion editor for
The Washington Times ad started
associate editor at RealClearPolitics
and Jonathan Swan national political
reporter for Axios a B I know this
caught people up on the hill by surprise
it caught a lot of people by surprise it
had been in the whispers in the wind
possibilities but when it happened there
were a lot of people shocked up there
yes good and bad shocked Republicans
were exuberant it was really hard to for
the Senate Majority Leader to sort of
stifle his smile when he got that Senate
Senator McConnell like in party face
yeah we use it was really is it was
hilarious
and and then for Democrats this is a
very very tough day one senator today a
Democrat told me that the retirement of
Kennedy is sort of putting it off and
putting it off and hoping to delay it
was one of the last prayers at night
when the head
at the pillow and this is very very very
profound for them about not just what
the what the vote is gonna do and what
how will juice turn out in the midterms
excite Republicans and conservatives but
really what it means about the impact of
these decisions going forward but a lot
of decision today about unions yes that
really hits unions pretty hard and also
a big fundraiser for Democrats so
President Trump has I sort of think
about it as two phases of the way he's
thought about the court the first phase
is he thought he has thought
subsequently and I think it's correct
that it was a masterstroke a political
master track of his to release that list
because it was really important to
Republican base voters it energized them
and so he sees that list as partly
responsible for his victory so that's
the first way he saw the cause no wrong
about that if you look not wrong not
wrong about it but now he sees the real
practical effects of the court and he
has learned that this week and
particularly over the travel ban because
you had liberal courts timing the travel
ban and this week it was upheld by the
Supreme Court so Trump now knows both
the political force of this decision and
the practical agenda force of this
decision Charlie the to listen to
Leonard Leo who's advising President
Trump on his next picks and and also
advised on Neal Gorsuch there's really
right the list that's right yeah there's
really nothing Democrats can do other
than trip up a potential candidate no
and I think that you know by any
schedule you know there ought to be
someone confirmed by November so we're
looking at something it's gonna probably
happen before the election what will be
interesting to see is what will those
senators from those states that you know
obviously Trump is targeted senators
from states that overwhelmingly voted
for Trump is it gonna make it very
difficult for them to vote against a
nominee by Trump this is the sweetest of
sweet spots for Trump this is the thing
that unites the establishment with the
with the mega folks and and you know the
the greatest never Trump or has to admit
that Neal wore such was it was a huge
success and that the that the list that
he picked from was a huge success as
Jonathan pointed out and that that if he
if he will stick to this again because
it's worked very well for him and it's
in all likelihood going to be another
huge success so he's talking about that
John testers now Heidi Heidi camps and
the Claire McCaskill's and the Joe
Donnelly's they're gonna be answering a
ton of questions now in these races
about how potentially they're gonna vote
these are all the Democrats defending in
red states essentially Trump states I
minimum two of them vote for the nominee
from that list whoever it is absolutely
minimum two maybe more but the idea of
senator Gillibrand and and other liberal
senators perspective twenty twenty
candidates saying oh we're not gonna you
know allow hearings they don't run the
Senate no one cares if they show up at
the hearing trying to grind the Senate
to a halt to try to stop this is m'p the
filibuster on the laughs on meal course
which they never shut up it was a huge
mistake they're just gonna add insult to
injury for themselves it really is it's
it's going to be a mistake to pressure
those senators those Democrats you just
names who are up in cycle by trying to
to shut the Senate down and stop this
it's not stoppable and they need to take
their toys and go home here's the
president and the leaders of the Senate
we will begin our search for a new
Justice of the United States Supreme
Court that
we'll begin immediately the Senate
stands ready to fulfill its
constitutional role by offering advice
and consent on president Trump's
nominate to fill this vacancy we will
vote to confirm Justice Kennedy's
successor this fall our Republican
colleagues in the Senate should follow
the rule they set in 2016 not to
consider a Supreme Court justice in an
election year well I wasn't the rule it
was a presidential election year and you
know you go back to President Obama who
had a vacancy filled in August before a
midterm election there are obviously a
Democrats we'll make the case that they
should hold on until after the election
but they really don't have the backing
people in this environment will use
whatever tools they can to advance their
agenda there are no rules there are no
standards of principle anymore it was
just whatever you can do to eke out an
advantage so again you said it you said
it best first their only tool is to have
trying to prevent him getting the votes
to get through that's it and the whole
ball game of those 10 red state senators